(gentle music)
(audience applauds)
- Welcome back, everybody!
We are here with Nick Jonas
and Wendy Raquel Robinson.
(audience cheering)
- Whoo!
- So, in honor of
Nick's love of golf,
and my love, personally, of Top golf.
(Kelly imitates horns)
(Wendy laughs)
And our shared love of popcorn,
who doesn't love popcorn?
It's time for a new game, everybody,
called, "It's In The Bag."
♪ Mm it's in the bag ♪
You said, "Mmm!", 'cause
it was good popcorn.
Okay, Wendy has graciously agreed
to host this game as I destroy Nick,
so could you tell us how the...
Do you like how I'm
trash talking' already?
- There's zero chance you destroy me.
- I love it, I love it. Trash talk!
Okay, absolutely, all right.
Now Kelly and Nick,
they each have a bucket
of practice golf balls.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Now, Kelly, you have the red balls,
- And Nick, you have the
yellow balls, all right?
Now, the point of this game,
no pun intended,
is to hit those balls
at the board behind us.
- Okay.
- Get them to stick to the
areas with the most points.
Now, I'm gonna be the judge, yes!
And I'm gonna tell you how
many points a shot scores.
Nick, you're playing for
the men in the audience,
- Mm-hmm.
(Kelly boos)
(men cheer)
- And Kelly, you are
playing for the women-
- Yes!
- So make us look good.
(women cheer)
- [Kelly] Female victory.
- Yes!
Now, the player with the most points
will win a prize worth
$300 for his or her group.
So Nick, you're up first.
- All right.
- Let's get into position.
- [Nick] Let's do it.
- [Kelly] All right.
- [Kelly] Don't feel pressured.
- [Nick] Okay, here we go.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Wendy] Uh-oh.
- It's been fun knowing you.
(Wendy laughing)
(Kelly gasping)
(audience cheering)
- [Wendy] All right.
(bell dings)
- Come on, Kelly! Come on, Kelly.
- You've got this, Kelly.
- Yeah, we've got this!
- You got it! Go Kelly!
(crowd cheering)
- Totally. Totally.
- [Wendy] Hit that ball, girl.
- Okay. Okay. Okay.
- You can do it.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
(Wendy cheering)
- It's like, close to four.
- [Wendy] Yes, I see a four!
- [Kelly] It's close to four.
- [Wendy] It's a four.
- Okay. Good shot, Kelly.
- God bless.
- [Wendy] Three to four.
Let's go. Three to four-
(audience groaning)
- [Kelly] Okay. That's-
- [Nick] It's outside.
- [Kelly] That's called the abyss.
It's in the middle of nowhere.
- [Wendy] I'm a judge. I'm gonna say
- -no? Four?
- [Kelly] I think it's--go
for it. You're the judge!
- [Wendy] Sorry, Nick.
I love you. Biggest fan.
- [Nick] It's Four. Four.
- [Wendy] It's one.
(bell dings)
- [Kelly] Ooh!
Okay, okay, okay.
- [Wendy] Oh, God. He's mad.
- [Kelly] I love that
you're aiming for a number.
I'm just aiming to hit it,
like, it's like, okay, okay.
- [Nick] You can do it.
- [Kelly] Where? Okay, I can do this.
- [Wendy] Let's go.
- [Nick] Another four!
(bell dings)
(audience cheering)
- Hm, hm, hmm.
- [Nick] Okay.
- [Wendy] I'd say five, four. It's a four.
- [Kelly] Okay, I like it. I like it.
I like cause it's a popcorn.
- [Nick] All right, all right.
- [Kelly] Three! Man, you hit it.
You're like actually hitting the numbers.
- [Wendy] What is that?
So Kelly, it's your
turn, and what is that?
That's a four.
- [Kelly] I just...
- [Audience Member] Seven, eight.
- [Wendy] Seven, eight.
Thank you baby I can't count.
- [Nick] Seven, eight.
- [Kelly] I just love--
- [Nick] It's close.
- [Kelly] I just love that he's actually
nailing the numbers,
it's great for you, Nick.
(Wendy laughing)
Here we go. Here we go.
- [Wendy] We'll make it count.
- [Nick] One.
- [Kelly] Oh. It's one. Okay.
- [Wendy] It's a one.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Wendy] It's a one. It's a one.
So, what does that score all together?
Seven, nine.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Wendy] And the goose drank wine.
- Yeah.
- [Wendy] Yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh, two, two.
- [Nick] Two.
- [Kelly And Wendy] Okay. Okay.
- [Nick] Hi.
- [Kelly] Here we go. Here we go.
Okay.
- [Wendy] Nine. Nine.
- [Kelly] Oh.
(buzzer)
(audience groans)
- Oh my god.
That was my eye.
No, I'm kidding.
- [Nick] You can redo
it again if you like.
- I'm afraid I'm gonna
hit Wendy, honestly.
(Wendy laughing)
- So basically this, this could win it.
- [Kelly] Oh, is this, are
you rubbing it in, Nick?
(Kelly and horn drown out Wendy speaking)
- [Nick] I have to miss.
I have to miss completely.
- He got it, he won.
- Oh, that's three.
(bell dings)
That's three.
(Crowd cheers)
Okay, so here we go, here we go.
- [Kelly] Okay am I doing one more?
I think he just wins.
Let's just be honest.
- 12, nine.
- I think it's a tie.
- [Producer] One more shot.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Wendy] Okay.
Here we go, make it count.
This is for the ladies.
- [Nick] Come on Kelly.
- This is for the Ladies.
(audience cheers)
- [Audience Member] Go Kelly.
(Everyone cheers)
(bell dings)
(triumphant band music)
(Wendy screaming)
- Thank you.
- Well played.
- Thank you for helping me.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] All right.
That's the game.
Okay, so of course everyone is a winner,
so don't worry, men.
Top golf, literally, this is not,
I'm not being paid by them.
I love them.
One of my favorite places on the planet
if you haven't been, you have to go.
They offer a no golf knowledge needed,
which is why I fit in.
You don't have to have
golf experience where
anyone can cut loose and have
a good time while golfing.
They have drinks.
The dining is so good.
I'm telling you, you
think it's not gonna be
and it's so good.
There are 86 locations globally
and more opening every year.
Trust me, it's a fun time.
Go with your friends and family.
Everyone in the audience is getting
a $300 gift card to Top golf.
(audience cheers)